be advised we are traveling at 115
mph speeds approximately 95 M hour in
some Texas counties near the border
high-speed chases involving cops are up
as much as
1,000% what is going on the answer is a
4.5 billion border militarization Plan
called operation lonar the program has
mobilized a third of Texas State Police
to crack down a migrants what that means
is highspeed chases lots of them
high-speed police chases can be deadly
and the pro program's first 2 years
almost 200 people have been injured and
74 people have been killed but it's not
just migrants who get hurt innocent
bystanders are also killed in these
Pursuits including this 7-year-old girl
and her 71-year-old grandmother we have
a problem at the southern border but
high-speed police chases aren't the
solution